well in this contest of course um
everyone gets a vote to decide who they
want to go to the final two and our next
guest syrian duncan smith the former
conservative party leader has decided to
back liz truss he says that she's right
on the economy and has proved herself on
the world stage we're writing in the
telegraph this week he said that only
list trusts understands that getting the
burden of costs down while helping the
poorest will be the only way to deliver
for the british people although she's
the longest serving cabinet minister in
the running liz trust may be surprised
to see the level of support for some
other candidates emerging
we can talk now to sit in duncan smith
shall we who knows all too well what
it's like to win and the support of your
party in a leadership contest thank you
very much for being
with us and i just want to react firstly
to a few things that dominate raab was
saying
he was talking about tax cutting
and of and spending squeezers and saying
that yes you can judge everyone on their
record shouldn't we be judging his trust
on her record as well
yeah of course you have to judge
everybody on their record in fact that's
one of the things i've been maintaining
that we can't have anybody rise without
trace we do need to know after all most
of the main candidates in this debate
have all been in government for the
better part of two and a half years so
it's very important to know what their
record says about them when they have
the power to do things and i think
that's very important liz's on record
you know she's done these phenomenal
trade deals particularly with australia
by the way which wasn't to follow on
trade deal and also the trans-pacific
partnership which opens us into the far
east which is really delivering brexit
and the other one of course she stood up
at ukraine she's been very very strong
about our involvement support for
ukraine
which is a really really vital issue and
also now northern ireland where she's
helping resolve that so her record is
strong but if you come to the issue
which you said was taxation there is a
genuine debate to be had here in the
party about this
because i think the government and the
treasury through a sort of peculiar
orthodoxy is bound on the wrong course
which could seriously damage us over the
next two years looking at this though
because obviously you know tax cuts it's
one part of the debate and fiscal
responsibility i guess is part of it um
if you look what liz trust has promised
to do to reverse the rise in national
insurance to cancel the rise in
corporation tax act screen levies on
energy bills allowing families to share
their tax allowance
according to the ft that will cost over
30 billion pounds a year how's that
going to be funded yeah she's talking
about a whole series of potential taxes
that you can deal with which will help
first of all let's face what the problem
is the problem is
it's
something to do the fact that outside
there's demand is outstrip supply post
the pandemic the
remarkable lockdown we've got an
inflationary spiral going on now we've
got the war in ukraine that's maybe even
worse with regards to energy but here in
the uk
we do have to bear some of the blame for
the fact that we have inflation rising
on top of all of that and that's down to
the bank of england and the treasury's
failure over i think uh monetary policy
so first of all over a year ago well
this is important uh the bank uh
actually kept on printing huge sums of
money which inflated the economy as well
as keeping interest rates low now it was
the treasury that signed off on that
money printing to chancellor no less and
so before they say oh it's independent
treasury has the right to say no to the
money printing bit and they didn't just
because that has fueled inflation so
inflation is now domestically a problem
we have to deal with that who are you
talking about signing off on this well
the chance to signed off on the uh on
the extra money that was printed
talking of course it did because the
the treasury has the right to say no
um between them and the bank frankly i
think they got that one wrong then the
second point is okay inflation is a big
problem because it takes away people's
earnings and their savings
and this is where liz is right about
this which is you now need to have to
look at two things though we have to get
inflation down and at last the bank is
raising interest rates and that should
begin to bring this under control but at
the same time if you end up
by trying to target that so exclusively
that you end up with the highest tax
rate that we've had since the 1940s you
will crush the economy at the same time
now at the same time just to come in
because many people would argue that
actually if you're looking at tax cuts
and that does have an inflationary not
necessarily just just just to continue
uh wish you so next time the debate
borrowing your way out of inflation is a
fairy tale uh paul johnson of the ifs
saying that it is correct that tax cuts
funded by borrowing could potentially
increase inflation it may result he says
in the bank of england increasing
interest rates a little bit further the
opposite of what
we would want to happen and a little bit
faster than the otherwise would have
done and that's confusing two things
first of all no one's talking about uh
tax cuts but aided by borrowing here's
the problem well listen let me get to
the root of this the problem right now
we face is that the treasury is bound on
the wrong course why is that because if
you have the tax rates at the rate they
are now
with more to come the corporation tax
you are going to bring our economy into
recession that's what's forecast now if
we go into recession whilst we have high
inflation that's stagflation which means
it's like an aircraft so how is that how
is list trust funding for tax cuts very
important so
then if you end up in a recession what
happens is your revenues from your tax
receipts fall what happens then you
increase your borrowing because you
can't meet your commitments so now
actually the plan they got will actually
increase borrowing not reduce it at all
make it even worse lowering tax key
taxes
absolute taxes that bring down
that risk and therefore allow the
economy to grow and the economy growing
is critical to get us through this in
the next 12 months that means we won't
need to borrow more money to fund those
taxes what we're going to do right now
is borrow more money because we'll go
into recession and we will not be able
to meet our existing commitment so the
30 billion tax cuts
just talk to me about the funding for
that she's talked about the range of
what we can do that covers all of the 30
billion but if you look carefully
well i'm going to tell
the treasury has headroom the government
right now in the last two years their
receipts exceeded their forecasts by
wait a minute but the 30 billion head
room is under question because of the
poorer outlook of the economy that
you've just been talking no no we've
actually seen already better growth than
we thought was going to happen earlier
in the year that will fall away but the
key point all the independent economists
will tell you this you have headroom two
points the receipts that came in over
the last two years have far exceeded
anything that was forecast by about 180
billion you have an extra 30 billion but
you also have something else which is
very important you have the flexibility
within all this because right now even
now the government is inflating away one
large section of their debt that debt is
the index linked deck which because of
inflation they're getting and the third
area they're getting they already have a
windfall tax because the windfall tax on
things like the cost of the pres
the tax they're getting on petrol on vat
these things are all coming in faster
and harder so their revenues have
increased dramatically we're saying put
some of that back into reducing the
burden on people so they don't suffer as
they're going to suffer if we head into
recession so if things have been better
than predicted should rush you've seen
it get a bit of credit for that what
rishi sooner should do is use the money
because this is down to the accidents of
inflation so the key point here is the
treasury is wrong if you crush both
growth in the economy and high high
interest rates you will destroy the
outcomes for lots of people we need to
get that right growth is critical and
tax reduction key tax reduction will
actually help aid growth and that's
vital um you mentioned at the beginning
interview about the importance of people
who have been tested
and you perhaps said to me earlier this
week as well you did say to me earlier
this week that you're not sure what
penny mordant has done for the last few
years
what did you mean by that i just said
that everybody's record should be fully
open and examined about your
achievements
my point is we've had two and a half
years post brexit where everybody bar
tom tugenhat i think is in government
everybody needs to be judged on what
they've achieved and that's the whole
campaign
and liz trust is open
rishi sunak's open kemi's open the one
person i personally don't know what her
big achievements are is penny i don't
have any problem with her no issues at
all but for me it's about
the key thing is we're not electing a
leader of the conservative party that
has two years to build their
their reputation we are electing someone
who will be prime minister on day one so
you need to know when they had power and
authority in government what did they do
with it what did they get what did they
achieve what were their main beliefs
what did they drive through what tough
decisions did they have to take that
actually they had to sometimes go
against their civil servants to get
these things done i mean i ran a
department for six years work seven days
a week i know what it's like to make
tough decisions so the key thing is i
want to know
where are these tough decisions from all
of them it's not to be aimed at her it's
all of us so all the candidates need to
be completely open about that and argue
i know what it's like to take tough
decisions because this is what i did
what are the big things and you're
concerned that penny mordon well of all
the candidates if i was standing look at
the one i don't know enough about what
she's actually done i know what the
others have done so i want to know what
does she believe her big achievements
are and where was she actually fighting
for things how many hours did she spend
working at this where did she face those
tough decisions you know were you
questioning about lord frost's um uh
intervention where he's sorry lord frost
uh who said that he um effectively uh
was she went missing when she was
portraying minister in his words
well that's his view i don't know i've
not worked with her so all i'm saying is
this just leads the whole point we need
to know what what actually does she
believe about it uh because obviously he
and others don't think so i want to know
what is your real key area to be able to
say i can land two feet in downing
street and govern from day one because i
know what it's like to take tough
decisions and that's the key element for
me for choice um a recent uh concept of
home poll not weighted we should say but
still useful um has said that kevin
badenock appears to be uh their choice
for who should be the next leader of the
conservative party you can see there
she's um
well quite quite sizably ahead of uh liz
truster do you think that she could end
up being on the final two the candidate
of the right well i'd have no problem
with uh kemi and liz being on the final
two i think the members would get just
the two that they want to fight and uh i
think liz will will win because of a
experience like kemi a lot i think she's
don't get me greater
a very good candidate uh but i think liz
is the one that has the greatest depth
of experience and and let's face it
whatever else in this uh kind of uh
fashion show candidates the truth is
only one thing matters are you going to
be the person capable on the day one
that you stop in downing street two feet
on the ground governing from that moment
with the character and the grit to be
able to do unpopular things and get them
done first and i think that's where liz
scores just very finally i want to ask
you about the front page of the observer
which is about alex sharma who's been
obviously doing a lot of work with the
government on the climate change agenda
he says that he could quit his role uh
if they push some of the candidates
obviously talking about scrapping the
commitment to net zero
he says he could quit if that happens
well i'm sorry he he feels that actually
i thought in the case of the debates the
key thing is we face a number one crisis
which is cost of living inflation where
fuel at the pumps etc is very high uh
there are moments when sometimes even if
you want to achieve something and lizard
said she does still want to achieve a
net zero
every now and then sometimes you have to
say well for the moment we have to just
put that slightly on the back burner
whilst we make sure people don't suffer
and we have the capacity to reduce the
burden on them by getting rid of some of
these green levels you can come back to
that process when we get through this
but for the moment if you ask anybody
out there what their key problem is they
need to get to work in the morning they
need to be able to afford to buy their
food they want to be able to heat their
homes come the winter these things mean
we need to do more gas and at the same
time relieve people of those extra
levees because this is what really
matters to here and now yes we want to
get to net zero but we need to do it in
a way that we don't crush the public
while we're doing it and make sure that
the things we do are absolutely right
but this is talked about modular
reactors more emphasis on gas as a
transitional fuel after all we sit on an
island of gas and oil we should be using
the gas and we might be able to help
europe as well get off their addiction
to russian oil and gas if we weren't
pumping it to them okay thank you very
much for being on the program at this
morning it's duncan smith